facebook critics have accused them of
covid misinformation on the platform and
this would support that theory
and it takes two to tango or in this
case three you have the public sharing a
fear-mongering link that maybe they
shouldn't you have the chicago tribune
may be writing a headline that is
fear-mongering and inaccurate that
scares more people and then facebook
building a platform that whips it into a
frenzy everybody is that fault the
tribune article has since been amended
and was mostly recently updated in april
here is the new update at the top of the
article update two weeks after getting a
covid19 vaccine a miami doctor died from
a condition that causes internal
bleeding although it developed suddenly
a medical examiner's report said there
isn't enough evidence to rule out or
confirm the vaccine was a contributing
factor
okay just like i said
you probably shouldn't have printed the
headline to begin with it's
fear-mongering and if people are
resisting getting the vaccine
printing it in a headline like that and
scaring people it might not be the most
thoughtful thing to do you might want to
think it through
and maybe
use a little judgment as a journalist as
a publication as a publisher as whoever
who wrote the headline and as we know in
a lot of cases the journalist themselves
doesn't write the headlines from social
media or somebody who's really good at
getting clicks rights and also from the
new york times
and here's the quote the report also
showed that a facebook page from the
epoch times an anti-china newspaper that
spreads right-wing conspiracy theories
was the 19th most popular page on the
platform for the first three months of
2021
and this is where facebook is super
weird these like epoch times headlines
and these weird publications
you've never heard about they've been
around for a short period of time
they have gotten a lot of play on
facebook because they play fast and
loose with the headlines etc not the
chicago
tribune is doing much better so the new
york times got this information by
obtaining leaked emails sent by facebook
executives they say according to the
article facebook executives debated
whether releasing the q1 report would be
a pr problem for the company duh
obviously it is the cmo alex schultz
initially wanted to release it but
eventually wound up agreeing to shelve
the report this shows you how insincere
the executives at facebook are they
literally are thinking about themselves
and the pr for the company and the share
price as opposed to what's in the best
interests of society and this important
discussion and just like you shouldn't
expect the journalists out there to be
acting in your best interest i wouldn't
expect facebook to act in your best
interest you need to act in your best
interest you need to be an independent
critical thinker hopefully this podcast
helps you all this is very interesting
because facebook released their q2
report last week vp of integrity guy
rosen said the social network had
undertaken a long journey to be by far
the most transparent platform on the
internet according to the new york times
i think that's patently false
twitter is public the data is public
twitter would be the most transparent
platform on the internet perhaps reddit
with all their voting being public and
comments being public
i think that's an actually factually
incorrect statement by guy rosen after
the article dropped on friday facebook
faced a bunch of online criticism
obviously from journalists as well so on
saturday night they decided to release a
pdf of their q1 transparency report by a
dropbox interesting which was
unavailable at the time it's recording
who knows why it could be they're
overwhelmed by people clicking it
on saturday facebook's head of comms
andy stone posted a thread and man it's
gotta be tough to have that job on
twitter describing the difficulties of
defining misinformation and what he
thinks facebook is guilty of here are
the most important tweets from that
thread but here's the quote we've been
getting criticism for holding an
internal report until it was more
favorable for us and then releasing it
getting criticism isn't unfair
getting criticism isn't unfair
okay
this is word salad but it's worth taking
a closer look and making note of some of
the components of the story that's more
weasel words you can tell this person's
a comms person because they talk like a
weasel andy stone on twitter continued
news outlets wrote about the south
florida doctor that died
okay correct statement when the coroner
released a cause of death the chicago
tribune appended an update to its
original story new york times did not
would it have been right to remove the
time story because it was covid miss
info that's a great question at what
point should facebook be taking stuff
down and interfering with the news
process i think the new york times in
the chicago tribune would tell facebook
or twitter or any social platform let us
do our jobs andy stone continued on
twitter saying of course not no one is
actually suggesting this and neither am
i but it does illustrate just how
difficult it is to define misinformation
he also added we're guilty of cleaning
up our house a bit before we invited
company we've been criticized for that
and again that's not unfair so he uses a
metaphor here which is a key part of
trying to persuade you to feel
a certain way about the company and the
job they're doing
cleaning up their house before we
invited company obviously everybody
wants to have a tidy house before you
invite people over
um
but that is a way to try and convince
you to not be critical of facebook
really the the problem with facebook is
this algorithm and their perverse desire
to increase time on site by any means
necessary and not really being
thoughtful about how their algorithm
works why does the algorithm need to
have these things spread why don't they
just put a cap no news story can spread
crazily or stories can only spread
within your friend circle times two or
something they they could throttle all
of this which of course with throttle
may be the time on site which they can't
do because they have quarterly reports
to hit and zuckerberg would never do it
because he wants to get the stock price
high we're cleaning up our house is a
reference to not publishing the q1
results because they didn't look good
obviously again he's just using a
metaphor to try to be convincing he's a
calms person he knows the power of
metaphors you're being manipulated by
those metaphors i'm just unpacking it
for you and meanwhile the q2 results
look better as most of the top posts are
memes and response bait for those asking
a question like oh what are your three
favorite movies or whatever
or what food is the most disgusting and
that might be a great solution for
facebook here if they want to have a
pragmatic solution for staying out of
the fray here maybe they just keep
politics and news stories out of the top
most shared stories they keep them
throttled to friends of a friend or
maybe two hops away and not let them
trend in some huge way on their system
is any of this sketchy by facebook
everything facebook does is sketchy
that's their mo they care about growth
above all else and really i think
at this point i think zuckerberg should
resign as the ceo of facebook and let
sheryl sandberg take it over and let her
make the decisions and i think she would
make more thoughtful decisions than he
does
or let somebody else take over and
let somebody who isn't as tied
with their net worth to the fate of
facebook run the company and do a better
job it's time for management to to turn
over at facebook that's my honest belief
there's other things zuckerberg could go
do with this life in the same way bezos
or bill gates have and he's young he
should go spend his fortune doing other
things whether it's philanthropy or
building other businesses or buying
other business or being a capital
allocator or playing you know with
oculus or spin out oculus and make it a
new company facebook is also facing
scrutiny obviously from the vitamin
administration you remember in july
biden said the platforms like facebook
are killing people due to the amount of
vaccine information which is let's be
honest a true statement and it's not
that facebook's killing them people are
conspiracy theorists they want to
believe this stuff there's a certain
number of people out there who will fall
for these conspiracy theories i think
they're inclined to believe them because
sometimes they do turn out to be correct
sometimes the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth is time
going by
and i know biden i think pull back on
that he's not wrong i think the bigger
picture here is it's time for zuckerberg
to go and i think you should go right
now put somebody in place put cheryl in
to be the ceo for now maybe she's into
her maybe she stays forever and that
would be just a much better look for
facebook and he should just give himself
a promotion to chairman of the board
according to the washington post white
house officials have alleged that many
americans are reluctant to take the
coronavirus vaccine in part because of
false misleading information they have
read on social media services including
facebook and americans didn't get
exposed to this information at scale so
it is a real problem my belief is that
these platforms need to look at the
algorithms and make decisions that are
in the best interest of society not
their own growth
do you ever wish you invested early in
some of the best performing ipos of 2019
and 2020 well our crowd investors did
and now you can join them in what's next
with our crowd accredited investors have
access to invest directly easily and
most importantly early
far-crowd investors have benefited from
archive companies ipowing like me and
lemonade or being bought by companies
like intel microsoft and oracle and my
favorite uber our crowd's professional
vc researchers identify promising
companies and funds across a range of
sector stages and global locations our
crowd is investing in medical technology
breakthroughs in ag tech and food
production solutions in the
multi-billion dollar robotic industry
and so much more so here is an easy call
to action you're going to just go to
archive.com twist
o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d dot com twist and begin
reading deal memos and you'll get to
invest in these amazing companies and
researchers you're working on if you're
interested in investing you need only
join our crowd there is no charge to
join just go to ourcrowd.com
dot com slash twist to open your free
account